IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY INTO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING AND THE-
STREET BUILDING. ASK ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. EYE INTO
THE HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO. TWO FOUR.
SIX TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND OR ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
TAIWAN AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOUR WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE. AND MUTED AND YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE
SUPPORT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I'LL BE MAINTAINING
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEDIAN. SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. WE HAD-
THREE SIX BILLS ARE TODAY ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. TWELVE SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALAN HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE HEARING. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. FILE ITEM SIX SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE THIS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL'S LIST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GLAZER
PRESENT GLAZER HERE NIELSEN
YEAH. NIELSEN HERE HERTZBERG
LEYVA FLAVOR HERE NEWMAN. OKAY
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AND SO
WILL PROCEED WITH OUR BUSINESS
THIS MORNING I DO DO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR FOR TODAY'S HEARING EACH
SIDE IS PERMITTED WATER TO LEAVE
WITNESSES EACH LEAD WITNESS MAY
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE WHICH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED A TOTAL OF TWENTY
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY INCLUDING
SPEAKING TIME OF ANY LEAD
WITNESS ALL RIGHT- TO BE CLEAR
WE WOULD INVITE- PRESENTERS TO
GO FIRST BUT TWO PRESENTERS
HAVEN'T YET ARRIVED SENATOR
NUMBER AGAIN SENATORS DEMAND
BECAUSE OF THAT I WILL GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED WITH THE
PRESENTATION I WILL DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE DONE.
DONE THAT YET RIGHT SO- ANY ANY
WHAT EVERYBODY HAVE ANY ISSUES-
ONE POINTED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY IS THERE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. RIGHT
CENTER LEYVA IS MOVED. AT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSOLE WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GLAZER AYE GLAZER HI
NIELSEN RIGHT NIELSEN HI.
HERTZBERG LEYVA FIVE LEYVA FIVE
NEWMAN. LEADVILLE THE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS THREE VOTE
TO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS OKAY SO I'M GONNA TURN
THE GAVEL OVER TO MY VICE YEARS
CENTERED NIELSEN FOR
PRESENTATION ON- 1439% PLEASE
SEE THEY'RE NOT. AB TERRIFIC
THANK YOU ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE WOULD
ENSURE THE PAY TO PLAY PROVISION
THAT APPLIES TO STATE AGENCY
APPOINTEES OR APPOINTED LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHEN APPROVING A
LICENSE PERMIT OR ENTITLEMENT
FOR USE ALSO APPLY TO LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHEN ACTING IN
IDENTICAL CAPACITY. THE LEVINE
ACT PROHIBITS AN OFFICER OF AN
AGENCY FROM ACCEPTING SOLICITING
OR DIRECTING A CONTRIBUTION OF
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS FROM ANY PARTY
PARTICIPANT OR THEIR AGENTS IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN THE
OFFICER KNOWS OR HAS REASON TO
KNOW THAT THE PARTICIPANT HAS
FINANCIAL INTERESTS. THIS
PROHIBITION IS IN EFFECT WHILE
THE PROCEEDING INVOLVING A
LICENSE PERMIT OR OTHER
ENTITLEMENT FOR USE IS PENDING
AND FOR THREE MONTHS FOLLOWING
THE DATE OF FINAL DECISION IS
RENDERED THIS PROHIBITION
APPLIES TO STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES COMPRISED OF APPOINTED
OFFICIALS WHO MIGHT BE RUNNING
FOR OFFICE HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT
LAW LOCAL AGENCIES WHOSE MEMBERS
ARE DIRECTLY ELECTED BY VOTERS
AND WHO MAY BE RUNNING FOR RE
ELECTION ARE NOT INCLUDED. IN
THIS PROHIBITION. CURRENT STATE
LAW COUNTER INTUITIVELY PERMITS
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS RUNNING
FOR REELECTION. TO SOLICIT AND
ACCEPT SIZEABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING
PERMITS OR LICENSES. FOR THEM.
BUT PROHIBITS IDENTICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO AN APPOINTED
OFFICIAL RUNNING FOR OFFICE
WHO'S AT ACTED IN EXACTLY THE
SAME CAPACITY. THE PROBLEM IS
SPECIAL INTERESTS SEEKING TO
INFLUENCE LOCAL DECISION MAKING
HIS LONG STANDING AND WELL
DOCUMENTED AND VERY REAL. FOR
EXAMPLE RECENT REPORTS SHOW THAT
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY. MORE THAN 30% OF
THE ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CURRENT
HUNTINGTON PARK CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS. CAME FROM EIGHT
COMPANIES AND THEIR EXECUTIVES
WITH PENDING REQUESTS FOR
CONTRACTS WITHIN THAT CITY. SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE EXTENDS
THIS PROHIBITION TO LOCAL
OFFICIALS. NOW THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES AN ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURE PRIOR TO A PROCEEDING
BY A PARTY. THE BILL ALSO
EXPANDS THE CONTRIBUTION
PROHIBITION TO INCLUDE SPOUSES
WHEN THE CONTRIBUTION COMES FROM
A BANK ACCOUNT SHARED WITH THE
PERSON. WHO IS AN APPLICANT IN
THE PRECEDING. FINALLY THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE TIME FRAME
PROHIBITING SPECIFIC
CONTRIBUTIONS. FOLLOWING AN
OFFICIALS ACTIONS FROM THREE
MONTHS TO TWELVE MONTHS.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THEIR LOCAL
OFFICIALS. AND CLOSING THIS PAY
TO PLAY LIEU PAUL WOULD PROVIDE
THE APPROPRIATE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY NINE. WITH ME THIS
MORNING IS JONATHAN MATUS DYING
WITH THE COP CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE TO PRESENT HIS TESTIMONY
IS WHAT MISTER CHAIR. FOR ME TO
START PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
GIVE US YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD
MORNING JOHNSON AT THE SIGNING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE. WE ARE PROUD TO BE
THE LEAD ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE THE
COMMONSENSE REFORM THAT WOULD
CLOSE A PAY TO PLAY WILL PULL IN
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT. WE
THANK THE CHAIR FOR AUTHORING
THE BILL AND THINK COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH THIS ON IT
SUBSTANCE. I CENTER GLAZER NOTED%
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
CURRENTLY LIMITS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF PARTY SEEKING A
CONTRACT PERMIT OR LICENSE FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN GIVE TO
APPOINTED MEMBERS. OF LOCAL
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS BUT DOES
NOT SIMPLY LIMIT THE SAME
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CITY COUNCILS
AND COUNTY BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS. THIS CREATES
BIZARRE OUTCOMES. AN APPOINTEE
OF A PLANNING COMMISSION THAT
MAKES RECOMMENDATIONS TO ACITY
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
WHO HAPPENS TO BE RUNNING FOR
CITY COUNCIL. WILL BE PROHIBITED
UNDER CURRENT LAW FROM ACCEPTING
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS FROM A DEVELOPER WITH
BUSINESS BEFORE THAT PLANNING
COMMISSION. BUT WHEN THE VERY
SAME PROJECT AND THE VERY SAME
DEVELOPER GO BEFORE CITY COUNCIL
FOR A VOTE. THE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THAT
LIMITATION AND CAN TAKE WELL
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
FROM THE DEVELOPER. THERE ARE
COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF THIS SORT
OF BEHAVIOUR HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL OF CONTRIBUTIONS IN
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS AND IN
SOME INSTANCES OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. UNDER SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE A PERSON
SEEKING A CONTRACT PERMIT OR
LICENSE OR THEIR AGENT OR THEIR
SPOUSE. WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GIVE A CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
TO APPOINTED OR ELECTED LOCAL
OFFICIAL WHILE THE CONTRACT
PERMIT OR LICENSE IS PENDING AND
FOR TWELVE MONTHS AFTERWARDS.
REFORMS OF THIS KIND ARE COMMON
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT. THE
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS FEDERAL
CONTRACTORS FROM DONATING TO
FEDERAL CANDIDATES. AT LEAST
FIFTEEN OTHER STATES LIMIT OR
PROHIBIT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR SUMMER ALL STATE CONTRACTORS
OR LICENSEES. AND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA CITIES THE CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE COULD FIND. LIMIT
OR PROHIBIT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM DEVELOPERS
AND OR CITY CONTRACTORS. WITH
BUSINESS BEFORE THE CITY. AS
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN IS A SIN BUT
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO ADDRESS
SPECIAL INTEREST MONEY AND
INFLUENCE IT CAN BUY INTO LOCAL
POLITICS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE HERE PRESENT
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE MODERATOR CAN WE GO
TO THE LINES FOR ANYONE CALLING
IN AND SUPPORT. YES ABSOLUTELY
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESSONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
AFTER YOUR QUICKLY GIVE YOUR
LIGHT NUMBER OFF LINE TO PLACE
IT BACK IN THE QUEUE. BUT I MAKE
SURE RUN S. B. R. FOURTEEN
THIRTY NINE YOU. MISTER CHAIR.
YES SIR FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
FORTY THREE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE NO NO FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ENOUGH THE FOURTEENTH THIRTY
NINE. OKAY THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
I HEARD THANKS A MILLION AND-
AGAIN. AS MR CARE SAID IF YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE THIS IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY HERE THEY'RE
ALL. AT THIS TIME AND WE WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
THREE YEAR OLD MAN. AT U. YEAH
HELLO THIS IS SURELY SURELY
KILLING US EVEN PLEASANT HILL
AND A SUPPORTER SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY NINE. PLEASANT HILL
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. WHY
FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ANDREW MUSE FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SIR. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE BY TWELVE
YOU ARE OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS CLIFF COPTER ON BEHALF
OF GOVERNMENT FOR CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR I KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP ALL
RIGHT SIR WOULD YOU INQUIRE OF
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
AND ALLOWING THEM THE CHANCE TO
TESTIFY. ABSOLUTELY I DO LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
OPERATOR CAN. GIVE YEAR LIGHT
NUMBER QUICKLY OFFLINE. ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE. AND NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
STRUCTURE AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE AUDIENCE HERE TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF OUR MEMBERS HERE.
UNDER WOLF THE US RESTAURANT I
HAVE A QUESTION I JUST WANNA SAY
I REALLY LOVE THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD- AND A QUESTION ABOUT
WOULD LOCAL CITY COUNCILS IF
THIS BILL WERE TO BE SIGNED INTO
LAW WOULD THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO CHANGE CONTRIBUTION LEVELS ON
THEIR OWN AT THE CITY COUNCIL OR
WITH THIS OVER RIGHT THAT.
THROUGH THE CHAIR THAT THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE ANY- LOCAL.
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT JUST
ESTABLISHES AN AMOUNT THAT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS BILL FOR-
FOR. CLOSURE AND
DISQUALIFICATION OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER THE
EVA. AND THERE WOULD BE NO OTHER
. INQUIRIES OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GLAZERS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TWELVE THANK YOU AT MISTER
CHAIR AT I- YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL-
WE ALL HAVE LIFE EXPERIENCES
WHEN WE COME HERE HAS THE
LEGISLATURE AND ONE OF MINE WAS
BEING ON THE CITY COUNCIL AND
BEING THE APPOINTED RAP TO OUR
SOLID WASTE AUTHORITY. AND IT
WAS AT THAT POINT IN TIME THAT I
LEARNED THIS CURIOUS QUIRK IN
OUR CODE THAT SAID THAT- AS AN
APPOINTEE OF THE SOLID WASTE
TORTILLA COULD NOT RECEIVE A
CONTRIBUTION OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS BUT AS AN ELECTED
LEADER THAT WAS NEVER A
PROHIBITION THEY STOP TO ME. AND
IT WAS THERE THAT I LEARNED OF
THIS- QUIRKINESS AND APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW AS A
SENATOR TO COME AND TRY TO CLEAR
IT UP AND AT AT THE AT. AT THE
HEART OF IT IS CREATING TRUST
AND CONFIDENCE IN THE DECISIONS
THAT ALL OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS MAKE AND I THINK THIS
BILL ADVANCES THAT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. IT FIRST
AND CONFIDENCE. AND NOW MOVES
THE BILL AND HUNDRED HAS MOVED
TO BILL. WE WILL PROCEED THEN.
THE ROLL CALL VOTE. FOR SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE GLAZER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI GLAZER
HI NIELSEN HI NIELSEN FIVE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI
NEWMAN. THREE THREE EYES WE
SHALL PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR SO THAT-
COMPLETES OUR CALENDAR FOR
AUTHORS THAT ARE PRESENT WOULD
REQUEST THE AUTHORS THAT ARE ON
OUR DOCKET TO PLEASE COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM SO WE CAN HEAR
THEIR BILLS. AND WE WILL TAKE A
SHORT RECESS WHILE WE WAIT FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU ALL.
STATE TO.
WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME SENATOR
UMBERG WHO IS HERE TO PRESENT S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATOR UMBERG
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
. THANK YOU. USUALLY GO FROM THE
PODIUM THERE BUT WILL MAKE A
SPECIAL ACCOMMODATIONS FROM YOU
THAT YOU CAN DO IT FROM RIGHT
THERE IF YOU'D LIKE A LOT I
DON'T WANT ANY SPECIAL
ACCOMMODATIONS. I WOULDN'T WANT
. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WELL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR SPONSOR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT SCOTT
MATSUMOTO- IN THE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK THE BILL TO WORK
ON THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE RECOMMENDED CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ALL RIGHT- TODAY I'M PRESENTING
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THE
DISCLOSURE CLARITY ACT THIS BILL
WOULD IMPROVE ELECTION
TRANSPARENCY BY UPDATING
CAMPAIGN ADVERTISING DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS. MAKE TV AND ONLINE
GRAPHIC AD DISCLOSURES. EASY TO
READ LEGISLATURE HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA DISCLOSURE
ACT IN THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
PETITION DISCLOSURE ACT. THIS
BILL BUILDS ON THAT WORK S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ADDRESSES AND
FIXES THE THREE MOST. USED
TACTICS. MAY BE ABUSED TACTICS
BY SOME CAMPAIGN COMMITTEES TO
AVOID TRANSPARENCY THAT'S
REQUIRED BY CALIFORNIA LAW. IT
WOULD REQUIRE ONLINE IMAGE
ADVERTISEMENT DISPLAY THEIR
DISCLOSURES ON THE SOLID WHITE.
OR BLACK BACKGROUND TO MAKE THEM
EASY TO READ AS CURRENTLY
REQUIRED FOR TELEVISION VIDEO
PRINT THAT. IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE ONLINE IMAGES THAT ARE
LARGE ENOUGH TO SHOW THE NAME OF
THE COMMITTEE PAYING FOR THE-
THE STOP FUNDER. FINALLY S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY WOULD REQUIRE
TELEVISION VIDEO ADVERTISEMENTS
TO DISPLAY THE TOP THREE FUNDERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IN YELLOW. AND
SEPARATED BY HALF A BLANK LINE
DISTINGUISH THEM FROM THE NAME
OF THE COMMITTEE. IT WILL ALSO
ENSURE VOTERS BEING ASKED TO
SIGN THIS REFERENDUM RECALL
PETITION. THE DON'T LIST IF THEY
DON'T LIST THE TOP FUNDERS ON
THE PETITION- THEN IT WOULD AN
INSTRUCTION AT EACH SIGNATURE
BOX NOT TO SIGN UNLESS THEY'VE
BEEN SHOWN THE SHEET. THAT
TRANSPARENCY IS CRITICAL FOR
OUR- POLITICAL PROCESS TO.
SURVIVE I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- THERE TO
WITNESSES- I BELIEVE MR MARC
POWERS IS WITNESS NUMBER ONE WAS
ON THE PHONE. TRAFFIC THANK YOU
CENTER ON BIRD WE WILL GO TO
YOUR WITNESS IS NOW AND YOU ARE
HERE FOR THE EARLIER
PRESENTATION BUT WE SAID TWENTY
MINUTES ASIDE FOR EACH SIDE IN.
TWO MINUTES FOR EACH OF THE TWO
POTENTIAL WITNESSES SO HI MISTER
POWERS- WE WERE RIDLEY READY TO
HEAR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I JUST
MARK POWERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERSASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE RADIO AND
TELEVISION STATIONS SERVING YOUR
DISTRICT AUDIENCES WE'VE WORKED
MANY YEARS WITH TRENTON IS
ORGANIZATION TO ENSURE POLITICAL
AD DISCLOSURES ACROSS MEDIA
PLATFORMS ARE FIRST OF ALL
SIMPLE AND EASY TO UNDERSTAND.
THAT THIS CLOSER SORIA
DISCLOSURES ARE SHORT AS
POSSIBLE AND EASY FOR THE
AUDIENCE TO HEAR OR READ WE
BELIEVE THAT DISCLOSURE CHANGES
PROPOSED FOR TV ADS IN THIS BILL
ARE REASONABLE AND ALLOW VOTERS
TO QUICKLY AND EASILY READ THE
TOP FUNDERS WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ANY COMPLAINTS OVER THE YEARS
ABOUT IT BEING DIFFICULT FOR TV
ADVERTISERS TO COMPLY WITH THE
TEXT DISCLOSE ACT. CURRENT
CHECKLIST OF REQUIREMENTS SUCH A
SOLID BACKGROUND FONTS SIZES AND
COLORS SO OTHER MEDIA
ADVERTISERS SHOULD NOT HAVE
DIFFICULTIES FOLLOWING EQUALLY
SPECIFIC AND CLEAR RULES
SECONDLY WE'VE COME TO
CONCLUSION DISCLOSURE SHOULD
ALWAYS BE FAIR AND CONSISTENT
THE VOTERS CAN EXPECT TO SEE THE
SAME INFORMATION ACROSS ALL
MEDIA PLATFORMS UNLESS THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT TECHNOLOGICAL
ISSUE WITH DOING SO FOR EXAMPLE
RADIO CANNOT CURRENTLY DISPLAYED
IT CONSISTSOF THE DISCLOSURES.
SO IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE
DISCLOSURE ITSELF DOES NOT
PROVIDE A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
FOR ONE MEDIUM OVER ANOTHER SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY WOULD NARROW THIS
GAP IN MANDATORY DISCLOSURES
BETWEEN BROADCASTERS NEWSPAPERS
AND ONLINE ADS THAT PRECEDE THE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
POWERS WILL GO TO YOUR NEXT
WITNESS MISTER TRENT LANG FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN MISTER LANG PLEASE
PROCEED. ADULT I MISTER LANG WAS
GOING TO TESTIFY IN PERSON AS I
RECALL- AND. HE DOES NOT APPEAR
TO BE HERE QUITE YET. AT THE END
OF LINES ESTRELA ON THE PHONE
LINE. OKAY WILL TAKE A PAUSE- ON
HIS TESTIMONY WILL SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WHO
IS TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY. THE MATHIS TIME
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN SIXTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR ANYBODY ELSE
HERE IN IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SEE NO ONE ELSE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN ASK ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY TO PLEASE
INDICATE. ARE YOU READY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT YES. IN SUPPORT
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA
HEAR OUR SECOND. LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
BUT NOW WE'RE JUST GOING FOR
OTHER. SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS OUT
THERE. OKAY I WAS JUST SO SWEET
YOU WANT IT FOR THE PUBLIC AT
THIS TIME YES SIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE WILL BEGIN
MISTER CHAIR WITH ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT THIRTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN CAN YOU HEAR US. THIRTY SIX ONE MORE TRY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY YOUR OPEN.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME. HEY WE
CAN'T GOVERNING WITHOUT MUCH
MIGHT EVEN SELL- I'M CALLING
FROM NORTHRIDGE CALIFORNIA NINE
ONE TWO TWO FIVE AND ALSO WITH
NORTHRIDGE INDIVISIBLE AND I
SUPPORT THE FELT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY SIXTEEN YOUR
OPEN. ONE SIXTEEN I'M I'M IN LOS
ANGELES AND- I'M ELECTED
DELEGATE- EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR NOW
FIFTY ONE AND A MEMBER OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WILL GO MY TWENTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS KATHY
CARLIN REPRESENTING SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY INDIVISIBLE AND I SUPPORT
AT EIGHT THIRTEEN SIXTY BECAUSE
IT GIVES TRANSPARENT VOTERS
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
JUST YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE AN INDICATION OF SUPPORT
. I WILL GO LINE TWENTY FIVE
MISTER CHAIR ARE EXCUSE ME
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWENTY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
DOROTHY WANAMAKER FROM NORTH AND
NORTH HOLLYWOOD I'M ALSO WITH
NORTHRIDGE INDIVISIBLE AND I AM
REGISTERING MY STRONG SUPPORT.
OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY. THANK
YOU MEANWHILE THE LINE THIRTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ART
WITH BLACK HERE OFTEN DELEGATE
ALAMEDA DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND- PLEASE WAIT
DEMOCRATIC CLUB. IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THANK YOU.
AND WEBER LINE THIRTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS EVIDENT IN
WITH PLACES FOR PROGRESS OUR
ORGANIZATION CAN CHECK AND
CLINICAL MAJOR DONORS SOME OF
WHO WOULD BE DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY THIS BILL. BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
PARA ASISTIR JUST YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION ALI'S. DOES YOUR
NAME ALIVE AND FOR PROGRESS
FAMILY SUPPORTED NOW THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WHITE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS JIM
DAVIDSON I'M CALLING FROM LOS
ALTOS AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. THE
FIFTY AMY HILL WE OF WALNUT
CREEK WITH INVINCIBLE SHOULD
RESISTORS OF WALNUT CREEK AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. I'M THIRTY FIVE YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
WE CAN LET YOU KNOW. ONE MINUTE
THE CONTROLLER OF VERA IN HAS
LIKE. IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. JERRY NICHOLSON MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA ALSO WITH CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CALLING IN SUPPORT.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY. THANK YOU
WIND NINETEEN YOU ARE OPEN. PAT
LANG LOS ALTOS HILLS REPORT S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY. LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ANDREW MAY STRUCTURE
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA NOR IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY. THANK YOU
. WILL BE ONE LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS THIS IS CAROL LEAD IN
WALNUT CREEK REPRESENTING THE
DEMOCRATS A WRESTLER WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER I TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO. PLEASE GO AHEAD WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OPERATOR HOW MANY OTHER
CALLERS WE HAVE IN Q. YOU HAVE
TO MARK THIRTY EIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. YES HELLO YES
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN YOUR INDICATION
OF YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
READERS BROWN- GAS STRONG LA
INDIVISIBLE- AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL STRONGLY GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. A LITTLE GIRL I KNOW IN
OAKHURST CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS SURELY SHOWING UP
FROM FLOODING HILL CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY AND CONTRA COSTA
MOVEON STRONG SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE OKAY
WE'RE GONNA BRING THE ISSUE BACK
TO- THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHERE
MISTER TRENT LANG HAS ARRIVED
MISTER LANG THANK YOU FOR.
SENDING ON BEHALF OF THIRTEEN
SIXTY THIS PC YES SIR A GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD TO
SEE ALL PERSON SORRY THAT MY
FLIGHT JUSTICE ARRIVES A LITTLE
BIT DELAYED BUT- WE ARE A PROUD
SPONSOR SB THIRTEEN SIXTY AND
THE GRATEFUL TO CENTERS ON BURKE
AND ALLEN FOR OFFERING THE BILL.
AND ALSO TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE- FOR WORKING WITH US
ON IT. WE'VE DONE THIS BILL THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO DISCLOSURE
CLARITY ACT BUT IT COULD BE MORE
AT. THE STOP ABUSES OF THE
DISCLOSE ACT ACT. BECAUSE IT THE
RESPONSE TO ABUSES THAT WE'VE
SEEN OF- OF THE- DISCLOSURE LAW
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED
ESPECIALLY ON ONLINE ADS TV
VIDEO ADS. AND MISCHIEF
REFERENDUM AND RECALL PETITIONS-
THIS BILL IS ALMOST EXACTLY THE
SAME AS SB SEVEN FIFTY TO THAT-
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED LAST YEAR.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH EXCEPT IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE CHANGES TO THE
TOP. CONTRIBUTOR THRESHOLD- AND
MESSAGES. THAT THE GENERATED OFF
. LAST YEAR. THE PARTS OF SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THAT FOCUS ON
OFFLINE. ADS ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONLY MAJOR TYPE OF POLITICAL AD
RIGHT NOW. THAT CURRENTLY DOES
NOT REQUIRE A BALLOT MEASURE AND
VALUE COMMITTEES. TO LIST AT
LEAST ONE TOP FUNDER. IF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION OF THE UNIT WAS SWAPPED
FOR LITERALLY MONTHS. BY A WITH
ONLINE ADS THAT HIT WHO WAS
PAYING FOR THEM. THE NEW RULES
PROVIDE ARE VERY SIMILAR TO THE
RULES FOR TV OF- AND PRINT ADS
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SUCH AS
CLEARED SPECIFIC RULES FOR- THE
DISCLOSURES POSITION BACKGROUND
COLOR FONT TYPES. SIZES AND
COLORS THAT MAKE IT EASY FOR
COMMITTEES TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY EASY FOR OTHERS TO
READ- GOOD GOVERNMENT A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
SEE SUPPORT THIS- WE PROMISED TO
WORK WITH OUR AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE ON- ANY CONCERNS OF
STAKEHOLDERS MIGHT HAVE IF WE'RE
STRICTLY. REQUEST RIGHT OUT
AGAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR LACK OKAY WE'VE-
COMPLETED THE TESTIMONY HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS ON
THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT. OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY WILL NOW
TURN TO. THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT UP THREE
ONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. RIGHT SINGLE GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN ASK IF THERE'S INDIVIDUALS
WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN SIXTY TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE. THANK YOU
ARE MISTER CARE IF YOU LIKE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN FIFTY.
NINE FORTY YOU ARE UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I'M ACTUALLY NOT IN
A POSITION ON THE SUPPORT
HUNDRED JENNIFER CANNOT BUT
SOMEHOW I COULDN'T GET ON I HAD
TO HANG UP. AND START AGAIN SO I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT ON BEHALF.
OF ALL AGE GROUPS THAT
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. RIGHT MODERATE IF YOU CAN
ASK ONCE AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN SIXTY. ABSOLUTELY AND
THE FINAL REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY. AND MISTER CARE NOBODY A
SCOPE WE'RE JUST GETTING ONE I
THINK RIGHT NOW ONE MOMENT-
THEY'RE NOT EATING THE RIGHT
COMMAND IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. SO THE
STARS ROSE ONE ZERO. RIGHT WE'RE
NOT GETTING ANYBODY TO QUEUE UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS COLLEAGUES
ANYONE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AT
THE CENTER NIELSEN MISTER
CHAIRMAN IBM I WILL OPPOSE THE
BILL. THERE'S A LONG LINE OF
ATTEMPTS I BELIEVE TO MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT PARTICULARLY FOUR
RECALL PETITIONS AND FOR. DIRECT
DEMOCRACY. I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY
BUT I DON'T SUPPORT IT THIS IS
NOT MAY BE OF MAJOR CONSEQUENCE
BUT IT'S- CHIPPING AWAY AT. AND
I'VE TAKEN THE POSITION OF EVEN
OPPOSING THAT CHECKED THE
CHIPPING AWAY AT THIS TIME I
THINK IT IS INDEED AN
INTENTIONAL ATTEMPT AT LEAST IN
PART. TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
SUPPORTING RECALLS AND DIRECT
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN CENTER I'M BERG-
IT'S TO CLARIFICATION ON THIS
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD
FOR TOP CONTRIBUTORS. PENSION
YOU'RE TAKING AMENDMENTS MAYBE
YOU COULD MAKE THAT CLEAR TO THE
COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF WHAT YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE THERE. WELL WE
ARE CONTINUE TO NEGOTIATE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- WITH RESPECT TO
FOR EXAMPLE VERY SMALL
COMMITTEES COMMITTEES UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
REQUIREMENTS THATMAY APPLY TO
THEM- BUT AT THIS TIME. OF THE
REQUIREMENTS CONTINUE FOR ALL
FOR ALL THOSE WHO ARE EITHER
POSTING OR AIRING IN OTHER WORDS
IT AT YOUR BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
THAT IN YOUR VIEW YOUR BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE THAT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR REQUIREMENT FOR
DISCLOSURE THAT'S THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY VERY GOOD. ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MR SENT OVER A GOOD GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL LIKE I DO HAVE
LET ME SAY FIRST DOING IT CREATE
WHAT. MISTER LANG AND OTHERS
HAVE BEEN DOING THAT FOR SOME
TIME- I SOMETIMES WORRY WERE
PLAYING A BIT OF A GAME OF WHACK
A MOLE. WHEN IT COMES TO. IT YOU
KNOW HOW SPECIAL AT THE- THE IN
THE INTERPRETER PERSONAL REALM-
YOU KNOW HOW SIGNATURE GATHERS
INTERACTING WITH A CONSTRUCTION
SITE I WILL PULL RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE-
CENTER NIELSEN ABOUT NINE I BUT
I DON'T THINK THIS PROJECT MARKS
YET THINGS PROBLEM WITH THE
MECHANICS THAT ESPECIALLY IN THE
WAY THAT YOU HAVE DIFFERENT.
GROUPS HAVE WEAPONIZED DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE PROCESS SO MY I DO
HAVE A QUESTION THOSE WHO SHOWED
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S AND YOU
KNOW I WAS FIND PUZZLING IS THE
NAMES OF GROUPS HOW HOW HAVE YOU
RETHOUGHT THIS DON'T THINK TO
STRESS DIRECTLY- BUT EVEN TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE REQUIRE YOU KNOW
THE NAMING- AS PROMISED POSSIBLE
THE GROUP SUPPORTS ON HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
THE CONFUSING NAME- PROBLEM BUT
YOU KNOW THERE'S A FIRST
AMENDMENT ISSUE OBVIOUSLY YOU
CAN NAME ANYTHING ANYTHING BUT-
MY CONCERN IS THAT THE AVERAGE
VOTER- ONLY LOOK SO DEEP-
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
INTERACTING WITH. A PAGE SIX YOU
GOT IT LET ME LET ME RESPOND AS
YOU MISTER LANG IS I RESPOND AS
WELL NUMBER ONE IS IT I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT WHATEVER WE DO
SOME INGENIOUS FOLKS. AT LEAST
ATTEMPT TO FIND A WAY AROUND
WHATEVER DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
WE PROVIDE- THE ESSENCE OF THIS
THOUGH IS IF YOU NAME THE
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW- MOTHERS FOR
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE- BUT IT'S
FUNDED BY X. Y. Z. ENTITY IS IT
THE X. Y. Z. ENTITY THE FUNDER
THAT'S WHAT'S IT IS ESSENTIAL BE
DISCLOSED AS OPPOSED TO THE
COMMITTEE NAY AND YOU COULD
CREATE A COMMITTEE NAME THAT.
YOU KNOW MOTHERS FOR EQUALITY
JUSTICE OF SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
ETCETERA ETCETERA JUST TO. READ
NAMES SO LONG THAT IT BASICALLY-
IT IT ELIMINATES THE PURPOSE OR
UNDERMINES THE PURPOSE OF THE-
OF THE DISCLOSURE BLANK SEEMS
ANGST ALSO WANNA RESPOND. AT HE
SAID EXACTLY THE RIGHT THING
ABOUT THAT I'LL JUST ADD THAT
THE CRUCIAL PART BEING THOSE TOP
THREE FUNDERS AND FOR INITIATIVE
PETITIONS MAKE SURE THAT VOTERS
SEE THAT TOP UNDER SHEETS OF A
SEA OF THEM. EXISTING LAW. DOES
HAVE YOUR MARKING RULES FOR
ABOUT WHAT MEASURE SO THE IF
SOMEBODY. USE MONEY TO US.
IDENTIFY BALLOT MEASURE OR- I
BELIEVE I BELIEVE WE CAMPAIGN
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THE BUT
DEFINITELY A BALLOT MEASURE.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO UP ONE
OF THOSE THREE FOR. ON THE CABIN
THEY GAVE OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ONE OF ONE OF THE
TOP THREE SO. THAT DOESN'T SOLVE
THE FUNNY NAME ISSUE THE FIVE
APRIL STILL BE THERE WE HAVE TO
SHOW THOSE. BUT THE TOP THREE OF
CONTRIBUTORS THAT THE REALLY
IMPORTANT PART WE BELIEVE. THAT
WOULD RESHAPE THAT AND YOU KNOW
THEN AGAIN AGAIN. AS IT RELATES
TO YOU TO IN PERSON
COMMUNICATIONS WE WILL CONTINUE
HAVE THIS PROBLEM WITH PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERS FOR FISHING.
ESPECIALLY PROFESSIONAL PITCHING
TOGETHER. AT A DO APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW YOU CAN SAY YOU KNOW THIS
PETITION MAYBE CIRCLE YOU YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ASK ABOUT A
LOT OF THINGS. YOU JUST TRY JUST
TRYING FOR YOU LOCAL STATER
BROTHERS WITH WITH SPECIAL
SECTION SIX AGO SO. THAT REMAINS
AN ISSUE TO MY MIND THAT WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE FASHION
BUT BUT SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
DEATH. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE CENTER NUMBER WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE UP JUST BRIEFLY-
ESTES AND THE NIELSEN I
UNDERSTAND SO NEILSON'S
CONCERNS. THIS DOES NOT
UNDERMINE THIS DOES NOT CREATE A
HIGHER BAR FOR EXAMPLE FOR
RECALL OR ANYTHING ELSE IT JUST
REQUIRES. ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURE
ACTUALLY EVEN MORE ACCURATELY
MORE PRECISE DISCLOSURE MORE
USEFUL DISCLOSURE. AND I URGE A
NO VOTE THANK YOU MR APOLOGIZE
FOR MY TARDINESS I WOULD AND I.
WILL THANK YOU CENTER AMBERG.
SEEN A LACK OF MOTION I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THIS KNOWLEDGE IDEA
SEEMS THAT I'VE- I'M GETTING A
LATE START UP I AS ON THAT SAME
FLIGHT I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL. AS SENATOR NEWMAN. HAS
MOVED THE BILL. AS A SAID TO
PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE- DEVELOPMENT
THEY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY- BURKE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI. HOPE IT WILL SEND
FROM HIGH TO KNOW ALMOST GOT ME
THERE. YEAH NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG
. LEYVA LEYVA HI NEWMAN NIGHT
NEWMAN I. ALL RIGHT CENTER
AMBERGATE LIVE PEERS AT THE BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
LEAVE AN ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK THANK YOU FOR
PROGRESS AND- WE ALWAYS HAVE
BEEN WITHIN. ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO TWO BILLS THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US FROM SENATOR
NEWMAN- CENTER IF YOU WANT YOU
CAN PRESENT FROM YOUR BODY SO
SURE VERY GOOD SO WE'RE GONNA
FIRST CALL. YOU. CAN'T GET OUT
THAT WAY WE CAN YOU KNOW. YOU
CAN'T MISTER I GUESS IT'S
OUTSIDE YOU CAN GET OUT OF ALL
RIGHT THERE. THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
A NEW HEARING OR THAT YOU. MOVE
ON SIDE OR THE OTHER YEAH BUT
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT IT YES
ITSELF. OR OVER THERE TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED THE DOORS ON THE OTHER
SIDE. BUT YOU CAN GO THAT WAY
LOOKS LIKE HE'S MADE IT LOOK ON
IT WOULD LIKE HE'S NAY. OVER
THERE YEAH. CENTERS NEWMAN.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE
TWENTY ONE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING AND MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- BEFORE I BEGIN
LET ME FIRST THANK COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS. AND NOTE THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
MENDING THIS BILL TO ADDRESS THE
CHANGES SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. SHOOTING SPECIFICALLY
STRIKINGLY ORIGINAL PROVISION
WITH LANGUAGE THAT STATES THAT
THE ONLINE PLATFORMS MUST
SUBMIT. ANY OTHER INFORMATION
SPECIFIED BY THE COMMITTEE IN
REGULATION. WILL BE STRIKING
THAT LANGUAGE THAT HAVING SAID
THAT I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY ONE THE
DIGITAL ADVERTISING TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OR DATA
ACT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
EVER USED AN ACRONYM WITH THE
BILL. VERY PROUD OF IT WHICH
WILL CREATE A PUBLIC PUBLICLY
MANAGED VISUAL ADVERTISEMENT
REPOSITORY. TO BETTER AND MORE
TRANSPARENTLY PROVIDE ACCESS TO
IN OVERSIGHT OF DIGITAL
POLITICAL ADS AS YOU KNOW
DIGITAL ADVERTISEMENTS HAVE COME
TO SERVICE POWERFUL TOOLS FOR
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS. THE
EPHEMERAL NATURE OF THESE ADS
WHOEVER MAKESIT MAKES LOCATING
THEM AND ADDRESSING AND
CORRECTING FALSE STATEMENTS A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE FOR THE
MEDIA RESEARCHERS GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WATCHDOG GROUPS. NOT TO
MENTION THE VOTING PUBLIC IT'S
HARD TO OVERSTATE THE DEGREE TO
WHICH POLITICAL ADVERTISING HAS
EXPLODED IN RECENT YEARS. IN THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTION CYCLE FOR EXAMPLE
DIGITAL MEDIA ACCOUNTED FOR ONLY
223% OF TOTAL POLITICAL AD
SPENDING. BY TWENTY TWENTY THIS
FIGURE HAD EXPANDED MORE THAN
6100% TO FULLY 18% OF TOTAL AD
SPENDING AND RUN NUMBER TERMS
COMPARED TO THE ROUGHLY SEVENTY
EIGHT SEVEN HUNDRED TO EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION SPEND NATIONAL
CAMPAIGNS. OVERALL IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ELECTION CYCLE BY TWENTY TWENTY
MORE THAN ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WAS BEING SPENT ON
DIGITAL ADS ALONE. IN THE FACE
OF THESE MONUMENTAL CHANGES
REGULATORS SUCH AS THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
AS WELL AS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH STRIVE PROVIDE VOTERS WITH
TRUTHFUL AND TIMELY INFORMATION
SUCH AS WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE CONTENT. IN THE PAYMENTS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE ODDS OFTEN
FACE DAUNTING CHALLENGES IN
POLICING DIGITAL CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISEMENTS DUE TO BOTH THEIR
TRANSITORY NATURE AS WELL AS
CAMPAIGNS ABILITY TO
PERSONALIZE. MESSAGES AND TARGET
SPECIFIC AUDIENCES. BECAUSE THE
DISCLAIMERS REQUIRED FOR
DISABILITY- ADVERTISEMENTS HAVE
GENERALLY BEEN MODELED AFTER
THOSE REQUIRED FOR PRINT OR
TELEVISION TOOLS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR LOCATING IN
REVIEWING. DIGITAL POLITICAL ADS
ARE GENERALLY LACKING IN FAILED
TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT LEVELS OF
TRANSPARENCY. THIS IS CREATED
REGULATORY GAPS AS NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE DEVELOPED AND
DEPLOYED SUCH AS REPLICATING ADS
WITH SMALL BUT DELIBERATE
CHANGES FOR MICRO TARGETING TO
SPECIFIC AUDIENCES. THE USE OF
GIFS AND MEMES BY CAMPAIGNS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS SUCH AS
FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM AND TICTOC.
AS WELL AS FOR CONTENT IN PEER
TO PEER TEXTING PROGRAMS
DEPLOYED BY POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
WHILE SOME ONLINE PLATFORMS
RETAIN TO MAKE AVAILABLE SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS ON THE RESPECTIVE
PLATFORMS. THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
POLITICAL ADVERTISING ON THESE
PLATFORMS DOES NOT REQUIRE ALL
DIGITAL ADS RUN ON THESE
PLATFORMS TO HAVE TO HAVE ANY-
CONSISTENT. FORMAT OR OR BASIS
FOR REPORTING SB NINE TWENTY ONE
TIGHTENS THE DEFINITION OF AN
ONLINE PLATFORM TO ENCAPSULATE
ALL OF THE VARIOUS DIGITAL AD
SPACES THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
UTILIZED. TO EVEN INCLUDE
CENTERS SUCH AS THAT UBER AND
LIFT USE THEIR OWN MOBILE APPS
TO DELIVER POLITICAL MESSAGING
TO THEIR INSTALL USERS AS PART
OF THE CAMPAIGN. TO ENCOURAGE A
YES VOTE FORPROP TWENTY TWO
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION CYCLE. THE DATA ACT
WILL CREATE A PUBLIC REPOSITORY
THAT WILL AFFORD VOTERS THE
MEDIA RESEARCH IS THE F. PPC AND
OTHER CAMPAIGN COMMITTEES AND
CANDIDATES ACCESS TO EVERY
DIGITAL POLITICAL AD. BY A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN OR COMMITTEE
FOR AT LEAST FOUR YEARS UNDER
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS ONLINE
PLATFORMS THAT ALREADY COLLECT
DATA. SUCH AS A DIGITAL COPY THE
ADVERTISEMENT THE PROJECT NUMBER
OF VIEWS- GENERATE THE ATTENTION
AND THE NAME AND IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
PAID FOR THE AD DOESN'T. WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THIS
INFORMATION TO THE AT THE PC ON
A STANDARDIZED FIVE DAY CYCLE.
THIS EASILY ACCESS FULLY INDEXED
DIGITAL ADVERTISING ARCHIVE WILL
APPLY ONLY TO STATE LEVEL BALLOT
MEASURES AND STATE LEVEL
CANDIDATES TO INCLUDE ELECTIONS
FOR STATE ASSEMBLY. THE STATE
SENATE CALPERS CASTERS AND
ELECTION CAMPAIGNS FOR STATE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS. AS
CAMPAIGNS INCREASINGLY SHIFT TO
INCORPORATE DIGITAL MODES OF
COMMUNICATION ADVERTISING
FACILITATING TRANSPARENCY AND
CREATING ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
THAT ENSURE THAT VOTERS HAVE
CLEAR VISIBILITY. INTO CAMPING
FUNNY BECOMES EVER MORE
IMPERATIVE HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS LINDSAY MCCAW ON-
SENIOR LEAGUE COUNSEL. FOR THE
F. PPC I AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU CENTER NEWMAN WILL GO
TO YOUR LEAD WITNESS LINDSAY-
MCCONNELL FROM THE F. B. PC.
MA'AM IF YOU'RE A HEARING
HEARING RUMOR ONLINE ON. SHE IS
ON THE ON ON THE CELL. BOB
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD INVITE
LINDSAY THE CONDO TO PROVIDE HER
TESTIMONY NOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE MY NAME IS
LINDSAY MAKANA SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
MISSION WITH THE SPONSOR SB
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR NEWMAN
THIS BILL ORIGINATED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
COMMISSION DIGITAL TRANSPARENCY
TASK FORCE WHICH WAS CONVENED TO
STUDY THE EFFECT OF THE
CONTINUOUSLY EVOLVING DIGITAL
LANDSCAPE ON CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISEMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE. THE TASK FORCE'S
MEMBERSHIP INCLUDED INDIVIDUALS
IN ACADEMIA CLINICAL
PRACTITIONERS AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM GOOD
GOVERNMENT GROUPS AS WELL AS
PLATFORM SB NINETY ONE WOULD
CREATE A PUBLICLY SEARCHABLE
CENTRALIZED LOCATION FOR DIGITAL
CAMPAIGN ADS OR STATE LEVEL
CANDIDATES AND BALLOT MEASURES
ALLOWING THE PUBLIC TO ACCESS
DIGITAL CAMPAIGN ADS THAT APPEAR
ON VARIOUS ONLINE PLATFORMS.
BECAUSE OF THE IMPERMANENT
NATURE OF DIGITAL CAMPAIGN AS IT
CAN BE DIFFICULT AND SOMETIMES
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A VOTER TO TRACK
DOWN AN AD BASED ONLINE
PREVIOUSLY FIND OUT MORE ABOUT
IT FUNDING OR REVIEW WITH
MESSAGING OR TO FIND OTHER
DIGITAL ADS ASSOCIATED WITH A
PARTICULAR CAMPAIGN OR ELECTION
UNDERSTANDING WHO AND WHAT
INTERESTS ARE BEHIND DIGITAL
CAMPAIGN AD HELP VOTERS WEIGH
THE VALUE AND VERACITY OF THE
ACT MESSAGE. THAT'S EMPOWERING
THEM TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
AT THE BALLOT BOX THE ABILITY TO
REVIEW ADS ALSO ENABLES THE
PUBLIC TO HOLD POLITICAL
COMMITTEES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
MESSAGING SB NINETY ONE WOULD
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND ENABLE
BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY I
PROVIDING VOTERS WITH A CENTRAL
LOCATION BE USED DIGITAL ADS
ACROSS ALL ONLINE PLATFORMS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CAMPAIGN OR
ELECTION. THANK YOU TO SENATOR
NEWMAN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR CONSIDERING THIS LEGISLATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THEIR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND MISS NICK
MCCONNELL WE NOW GO FOR OTHER
WITNESSES HERE. IN THE HEARING
ROOM OUT ON THE PHONE LINES. ARE
THERE ANY. HERE AND I ROOM
TWENTY TWO HIGH. WISH TO TESTIFY
IN FAVOR. I PICKED UP MY
CALIFORNIA MONEY CAMPAIGN WE
HAVE ACTUALLY NOT YET BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE A POSITION BUT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE- AUTHORS AND
SPONSORS WE BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
BE ON A TIMING ISSUE WE BELIEVE
WE WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO A
STRONG SUPPORT THIS IS A- VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE OF
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SEE NOW WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
CAN ASK IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO.
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB NINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE SO INDICATE. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AS HE
SAID IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN FALL BY
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT MISTER
FIRST WE WERE LIKE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING THIS IS
ANDREW MEARES FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. IN
FOR ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR SB NINE TWENTY
ONE WHEN FILED BY ZERO. IN ONE
MOMENT MEASURE WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER ONE QUEUING UP. ONE
FORTY FOR YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS DAVID
SCHMIDT. FINAL POINT HERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN YEAH I WANT TO-
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION I SHOW NO LEAD
OPPOSITION. WITNESS IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WHICH IS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE MOVING
FROM THEIR SEATS WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY. IN Q.
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU I DID I TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWENTY ONE
. SECURE NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT TERRIFIC WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. SENATE-
NINE NOT CENTER NEWMAN YOU CAN
CLOSE. YES THAT'S A SIGN OF A
GOOD PIECE OF LEGISLATION. AB
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRED AND
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MISTER
LANG THANK YOU TO THE LEAGUE-
FOR YOUR ACTIVE SUPPORT- THIS IS
ACTUALLY A LOGICAL COMPLEMENT TO
THE TO THE PREVIOUS FILMS CENTER
BRIDGE BILL- THERE IS CLEARLY A
NEED FOR A DESTINATION FOR A
REPOSITORY FOR. DIGITAL
ADVERTISEMENTS. WHICH OTHERWISE-
ARE ARE AWFULLY HARD TO TRACK
DOWN- IN WHICH AS I MENTIONED-
HAVING AN EVER INCREASING
IMPACT- ON THE ELECTORAL
COMPENSATION- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THAT THERE
IS A STAFF COMMENT A MINOR
AMENDMENT ON PAGE. SEVEN THAT
YOU ACCEPTED THAT BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
ON THAT THAT IS CORRECT MISTER
ROGERS ALL RIGHT. I RECOGNIZE
EMOTION FROM CENTER LEYVA TO
MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED- TO- TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THINK
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THAT'S CORRECT CONSULT
OKAY WITH THAT IF YOU WOULD.
CALL THE ROLL. SB NINE TWENTY
ONE NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. GLAZER HI GLAZER HI.
NIELSEN THEY. NIELSEN NOT VOTING
BOB HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN. FIVE ALL RIGHT WELL WE
HAVE EVERYONE HERE IS THAT RIGHT
AND WHAT'S THE VOTE CONSULTANT
FOUR FOUR ZERO OKAY THAT BILLS
OUT FOUR ZERO WITH ONE MEMBER
NONVOTING GRADUATIONS ON THAT
SENATOR NEWMAN. THE OF THE
SECOND BILL ON OUR AGENDA. SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE YOU'RE READY I
AM A SEAT ON THAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO NOW PRESENT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE- BEFORE I
BEGIN MY COMMENTS I WANT TO
FIRST THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS NOTE
THAT I'M GOING TO CUT. THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHICH NOW THE DEFINITION OF
ELECTION WORKERS WHO MAY AND
ROLE IN THE SAFE AT HOME
PROGRAM- NOW TO FILL AS I'M SURE
YOU WILL ALL AGREE FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS ARE HELD CORNERSTONE
OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IN RECENT
YEARS HOWEVER AND ANY CREASING
NUMBER. OF THE DILIGENT AND
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS
CHARGED WITH ADMINISTERING
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO THREATS
INTIMIDATION AND SOMETIMES
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE AT POLLING
PLACES IN THEIR OFFICES AND EVEN
AT THEIR HOMES IN THE AFTERMATH
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL
ELECTION IN UP TO THE PRESENT
THE PHENOMENON OF VIOLENT
THREATS THREATS AND HARASSMENT
OF ELECTION WORKERS. CONTINUES
TO CLIMB TO ALARMING LEVELS IN A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE NATIONWIDE
SURVEY AS MANY AS ONE IN THREE
ELECTION WORKERS SAID THEY FELT
THEY HAD FELT UNSAFE IN THE
CONDUCT OF THEIR JOBS WITH A
STUNNING ONE IN SIX INCLUDING
THREATS TO THEIR LIVES AS A JOB
RELATED CONCENS. SADLY THESE
CONCERNS HAVE BEGUN TO AFFECT
THE ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY STAFF
AND ADMINISTER ELECTIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY MORE
THAN 15% OF CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE LEFT
THEIR JOBS STUDENTS DIDN'T NO
SMALL PART TO THE MARKED
INCREASE IN AGGRESSIVE AND
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR DIRECTED.
TOWARD TEM OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN ENACTING PROACTIVE
MEASURES TO HOLD TO ACCOUNT
THOSE WHO WOULD SEEK TO
INTIMIDATE ELECTION WORKERS
THROUGH THREATS OR ACTUAL
VIOLENCE IT IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT
THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOW TAKE
SIMILAR PROACTIVE STEPS IN ORDER
TO HELP ELECTION WORKERS FEEL
SAFE. AND SECURE SB ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE WILL PROVIDE
PROTECTION AND PEACE IN MIND
PEACE OF MIND TO OUR ELECTION
WORKERS BY EXTENDING THE OPTION
OF THEIR ENROLLMENT IN ONE OR
THE OTHER OF THE STATE'S TO
EXISTING ADDRESS PROTECTION
PROGRAMS. CALIFORNIA HAS A
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
OFFICE OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CALLED SAFE AT HOME WHICH AFFORD
PROTECTIONS TO SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND PEOPLE WHO
WORK AT REAP REDUCTIVE CARE FOR.
SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WOULD
EXTEND ELIGIBILITY TO ENROLL IN
STATE IN SAFE AT HOME. TO INVEST
INDIVIDUALS WHO INTERACT WITH
THE PUBLIC IN THE COURSE OF
THEIR PERFORMANCE OF ELECTION
RELATED WORK. UNDER THE TERMS OF
SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE THE MAILING
ADDRESSES OF PEOPLE ENROLLED IN
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE SUBSTITUTED
WITH A MAILING ADDRESS. PROVIDED
BY THE SECRETARY STATE OR A
LOCAL AGENCY SO THAT ELECTION
WORKERS HOME ADDRESSES WILL NOT
BE INCLUDED. IN PUBLIC RECORDS
AND SUBSEQUENTLY PUBLICIZED
EXPOSING THEM TO THREATS. AND
INTIMIDATION SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE WILL ALSO EXTEND PARITY TO
ALL SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS. BY APPLYING THE
SAME HARASSMENT PROTECTIONS
CURRENTLY AFFORDED TO ELECTION
WORKERS UNDER THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS TO REFER TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AS WELL. ALSO UNDER THE
PROVISIONS INCLUDE ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE ELECTION WORKERS WHO FEEL
THAT THE PROVISIONS OF SAFE AT
HOME. MAYBE TOO CUMBERSOME MAY
CHOOSE TO BE ENROLLED IN THE
SAME ADDRESS CONFIDENTIAL
PROGRAM THAT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO PEACE OFFICERS AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL. THE INCLUSION
OF ELECTION WORKERS IN THIS
PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW THESE
WORKERS TO OBTAIN A SIMILAR
LEVEL SIMILAR LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIAL VOTER STATUS.
THEREBY ENABLING STATE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO RESPOND TO REQUESTS
FOR PUBLIC RECORDS WITHOUT
HAVING TO DISCLOSE THE PRIVATE
ADDRESSES OF COVERED. ELECTION
WORKERS SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
WILL ALSO ELIMINATE THE CURRENT
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR
PUBLICLY POSTING THE NAMES. OF
POLL WORKERS AT POLLING PLACES
THOUGH THE REQUIREMENT TO POST
THE POLITICAL PARTY AFFILIATIONS
OF POLL WORKERS ARE PULLING
LOCATIONS. WOULD REMAIN IN PLACE
THE BILL SPONSORS AND I HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS. TO ENSURE THAT SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE FULFILLS THE
NEEDS OF ELECTION WORKERS WHO
FACE THESE THREATS. ON A REGULAR
BASIS THIS LEGISLATION IS SADLY
VERY MUCH NEEDED IN ORDER
PROTECT THE CALIFORNIANS WHO DO
THE LARGELY THANKLESS. BUT
ESSENTIAL WORK OF ENSURING THAT
OUR ELECTIONS ARE FAIR FREE AND
EFFECTIVELY ADMINISTERED. HERE
WITH ME TODAY ARE KIM EXAM KIM
ALEXANDER FROM CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION. AND GALLERY
RAMACHANDRAN FROM THE BRENNAN
CENTER FOR JUSTICE AND I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN WE DO HAVE- TWO
MINUTES SET ASIDE FOR EACH OF
YOUR- OF THE- YOU HAVE IN ORDER.
THAT YOU WANTED TO FOLLOW THEIR-
I DO ACTUALLY I THINK KIM
ALEXANDER WILKERSON'S ALEXANDER
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION I'M KIM ALEXANDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION. AND AS NOTED IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS WE RELEASED A
REPORT LAST YEAR CALLED
DOCUMENTING AND ADDRESSING
HARASSMENT OF ELECTION OFFICIALS
TO SHINE A LIGHT ON THREATS TO
ELECTION OFFICIALS. AND THEIR
STAFF ONE THING WE CAN DO TO
ADDRESS THESE RISING THREATS IS
TO EXTEND. ACCESS TO ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY PROGRAMS TO
ELECTION ORKERS TO PROTECT
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION WELL
CONTINUING TO WORK AND PUBLIC
ELECTION ADMINISTRATION. LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS IN THE U. S.
R. 80% FEMALE AND MANY OF THESE
ATTACKS ARE GENDERED
MISOGYNISTIC ATTACKS. THOSE ARE
ON THE RECEIVING END OF THREATS
ARE UNDERSTANDABLY RELUCTANT TO
SPEAK OUT PUBLICLY ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE IN DURING BECAUSE DOING
SO CAN TRIGGER EVEN MORE THREATS
AND ATTACKS AND THEY ALSO. DO
NOT WANT TO GIVE THEIR ATTACKERS
THE SATISFACTION OF HAVING AN
IMPACT. THERE IS GROWING CONCERN
THAT IN THIS HOSTILE CLIMATE
PEOPLE WILL NOT WANT TO TAKE
THESE POSITIONS ALREADY 17% OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY COUNTY
REGISTERS HAVE LEFT THEIR JOBS
SINCE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY.
SOME CITING INCREASED AGGRESSIVE
AND ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR TARGETED AT
THEM. WHEN PEOPLE HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WALKING TO THEIR CARS FROM
THEIR OFFICES AT NIGHT WERE
RELUCTANT TO WEAR ANY ARTICLE OF
CLOTHING IN PUBLIC THAT
IDENTIFIES THEM AS AN ELECTION
WORKER OR LEAVING THEIR JOBS
ALTOGETHER WHEN THEY ARE
THREATENED WITH DEATH OR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE NAMED. WHERE
THEY HAVE TO KEEP A GO BAG BY
THEIR DOOR IN CASE OUR HOME IS
PICKETED WE MUST ACT. THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER FOUNDATION HAS
SUCCESSFULLY ADVANCED ELECTION
SECURITY FOR OVER TWO DECADES IT
WAS NOT UNTIL THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION WHEN WE REALIZED. THE
PHYSICAL SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE
WHO RUN OUR ELECTIONS IS AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF ELECTION
SECURITY TODAY. CALIFORNIA'S
VOTING PROCESSES ALREADY AMONG
THE MOST SECURE AND SECURE AND
ACCESSIBLE IN THE COUNTRY SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WILL HELP
ENSURE THE PEOPLE ENTRUSTED WITH
ADMINISTERING OUR ELECTIONS ARE
ALSO SECURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO TO YOUR SECOND WHEN HIS
WIFE LEAVES AVAILABLE ON THE
PHONE LINES- GALLERY
RAMACHANDRAN- IF YOU'RE THERE WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY NOW.
THANK YOU GLAZER VICE CHAIR
NELSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GARY VAN
CONVENT AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE BRENNAN CENTER FOR
JUSTICE BRYAN SINGER COUNCIL
ELECTIONS AND GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM. IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE COMMISSIONED A
SURVEY AND HELD INTERVIEWS WITH
NEARLY THREE DOZEN ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND OVER THIRTY ACTS
BURKE. CULMINATING IN A REPORT
WE PUBLISHED WITH THE BIPARTISAN
POLICY CENTER. IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR WE COMMISSIONED AN
ADDITIONAL NATIONAL SURVEY OF
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS.
THROUGHOUT THIS RESEARCH THE
OFFICIALS FOR AFFORDED ANONYMITY
IF THEY WISH FREEING THEM TO
SPEAK UP OPENLY. WHAT THEY TOLD
US WAS HEARTBREAKING. LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS FEEL UNSAFE
DUE TO HARASSMENT AND THREATS IN
THE WAKE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. SEVERAL OF THE WORKERS
WE INTERVIEWED REPORTED THAT
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS INCLUDING
ELDERLY PARENTS AND CHILDREN
WERE HARASSED OR THREATENED AND
MULTIPLE OFFICIALS TOLD US THAT
THEY WERE FORCEDTO FLEE THEIR
HOMES. A RECENT SURVEY IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOUND THAT ONE IN FOR
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS STILL
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
ASSAULTED ON THE JOB. ONE SIX
HAVE BEEN THREATENS THREE AND
FIVE WORRY. THAT DRESS WILL MAKE
RECRUITMENT DIFFICULT. MANY
RUSSIANS EXPECT THAT THE DID NOT
HAVE TIME OR- TO EVEN. OUT IF
THEY ARE THEIR STAFF ARE
ENTITLED TO ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY PROGRAMS STATE.
ENSURING THE ELECTION WORKERS
FEEL CONFIDENT APPLYING PRETTY
PROTECTION. THE KIND OF MEASURE
THAT PEOPLE OF ALL POLITICAL
VIEWS CAN GET BEHIND. FOR
INSTANCE OREGON RECENTLY PASSED
A BILL WITH BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THAT ALLOWS ELECTION
WORKERS TO HAVE THEIR
RESIDENTIAL ADDRESS MASK IN THE
VOTER FILE. CALIFORNIA CAN BE A
LEADER ON THIS FRONT. AS ASK B.
ONE ONE THREE ONE WOULD ENSURE
THAT ELECTION WORKER CAN
CONFIDENTLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE FULL FACE AT HOME PROGRAM.
WHICH NOT ONLY MATH PERSONAL
INFORMATION IN THE VOTER FILE
ALSO ALLOWS FOR THE USE OF A
SUBSTITUTE ACT PASSED WITH
MULTIPLE AGENCIES. ALTERNATELY
THEY CA APPLY WITH THEIR LOCAL
ELECTION ACCESS FOR VOTER FILE
CONFIDENTIALITY. THAT'S AGAINST
ELECTION WORKERS FOR DOING THEIR
JOB RIGHT THAT BEGINS THE MCAFEE
ITSELF AND THIS BILL. IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
PROTECTING THEM. GREAT THANK
VERY MUCH I MISS RAMA. I WE'VE
HEARD FROM TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF- ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
WE'RE GOING TO GO FOR. THOSE WHO
ARE STILL AT WANT TO TESTIFY TO
GET THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
INDICATION SUPPORT WILL START
WITH IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
ANYONE HERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
C. NUMBER GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR TO ASK ANYONE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN. FAVOR OF. SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE TO SO INDICATE
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR
OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE. PLEASE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY A PRESS
ONE- PLAYS THE ROLE AT THIS
TIME. WHEN FILED BY ZERO. AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH LINE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS BACKGROUND REPRESENTING
THE ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU FOR. I
FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. I AGAIN
DESERVE ANDREWS FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE WORK OF
ELEVEN THIRTY SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU. AND NEXT WEEK
WELL ONE MOMENT WE SHOULD HAVE
WON KEEP UP WITH THE SOME ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR FOR ANYBODY
OUTSIDE AT THE FINAL. THE FIRST
ONE FILED BY ZERO TO QUEUE UP.
FOR S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY ONE THEY
SHOULD BE WITH THE TWENTY SECOND
MY FORTY YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH JENNIFER HANNER ON
BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
GREEN JEANS A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF ELEVEN THIRTY ONE AND WE DO A
LOT MORE THAN THAT. IF THE
PERSON. THANK YOU. MISTER
CALDERON BODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME TERRIFIC WILL BRING
THAT MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MEMBERS. CENTERED
NIELSEN SENATOR NEWMAN WHAT YOU
SHOULD EXPECT THAT THE PEOPLE IN
SACRAMENTO ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
AND THE ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE NOT
TAKEN A POSITION HERE. THAT
WOULD SEEM LIKE IF THERE'S SUCH
A MANIFEST PROBLEM THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE CERTAINLY BEEN
ENGAGED IN THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
THERE'S A REASON. I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S A REASON SENATOR
ACCEPTED WITH THIS IS RELATIVELY
EARLY IN THE PROCESS OF CAPITAL
LETTERS. AND YOU SPEAK ENGLISH
YEAH YES SENATOR NIELSEN I'M WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH CCO AND
THEIR MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS THEY'VE ACTUALLY HELPED
CRAFT THIS BILL AND GIVEN US THE
SUGGESTION. TO REDACT POLL
WORKERS NAMES FROM PUBLIC
DISPLAY I'M SO THEY HAVE A LOT
OF INPUT ON THE DELAWARE HOPING
THAT THEY MAY WANT TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION BUT AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY. A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
IMPACTED BY THESE THREATS ARE
RELUCTANT TO SPEAK OUT PUBLICLY
ABOUT THEM THERE WAS AN INCIDENT
IN WASHINGTON STATE WHERE THEIR
STATE ELECTION DIRECTOR DID.
TESTIFY AND SHE WAS LATER
HARASSED AND DOXXED ONLINE-
FOLLOWING UP PUBLIC TESTIMONY SO
WE HAVE THIS SITUATION WHERE I'M
TALKING ABOUT THESE PROBLEMS.
RIGHT I'M PERSONALLY SOMETIMES.
RESULT IN EVEN MORE HARM BROUGHT
TO THEM. WELL JUST TO CHEN
OBSERVATION. NOT GOING TO TAKE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO WERE
SUPPORTING SUCH LEGISLATION.
WOULD BE MORE ADAMANT AND
BRINGING UP. THE BEST ELECTION
INTEGRITY AND SECURITY. IS
ACHIEVED BY LOCAL PRECINCT IN
PERSON VOTING. AND THAT WE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING THAT.
RATHER THAN SO MUCH ABSENTEE
VOTING IN THE DIRECT MAIL VOTING
THAT PRECINCT VOTING SHOULD BE
AT THE HIGHEST PRIORITY BECAUSE
IT'S THE BEST SECURITY. YOUR
NEIGHBORS KNOW YOU YOU KNOW YOUR
NEIGHBORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ARE CENTER
LEFT. BUT I JUST HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ABOUT-
VOTING IN PERSON I THINK THAT'S
THE IDEAL- I CHANGED TO PERMIT
AFTER ABSENTEE VOTING WHEN I
ALMOST MISSED MY OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE YEARS AGO WHEN WE WERE IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH- THE GROCERY
STORES AND I COULDN'T GET BACK
ALMOST COULDN'T GET BACK IN TIME
TO VOTE. SO I THINK WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT VOTING IS
ACCESSIBLE FOR EVERYONE AND
UNLESS WE MAKE OUR ELECTION DAY
A HOLIDAY SO EVERYONE HAS THE
DAY OFF AND CAN GO VOTE I THINK
THAT TO BE ABLE TO VOTE ABSENTEE
IS VERY IMPORTANT. CENTER THANK
YOU CENTER LIVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SEE NINE
CENTER NEWMAN IN A CLOSE M.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. SO THEY
ARE ELECTIONS WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT OUR BAR FOR YOU KNOW
WHETHER FOR CANDIDATES
REFERENDA. INITIATIVE SHE
RECALLS ARE PART OF THE FACTLY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OUR
PRIORITIES AND OUR PLANTS AS A
COMMUNITY AS A SOCIETY. IN
AMERICA WE CAN TAKE GREAT PRIDE
IN HOW FREE WHEELING HEALTH
PASSION THIS CONVERSATION CAN BE
BUT THE FOLKS WHO ADMINISTER OUR
ELECTIONS SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO ANY OF THOSE FRUSTRATIONS THE
PEOPLE WHO ADMINISTER ELECTIONS
SHOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE AND
SECURE AND SAFE. IN DOING WHAT I
CONSIDER THE LORD'S WORK IN
MAKING THESE- THESE PROCESSES
POSSIBLE THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY
THAT SADLY IT IS NEEDED- AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
WITNESSES- AND THE OTHER
SUPPORTERS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
NEWMAN- PRECIADO YOUR- ATTENTION
TO OUR WONDERFUL ACTION WORKERS
AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY LOOKING FOR A MOTION FROM
THE COMMITTEE OR SENATOR
HERTZBERG. IS MOVE THE BILL THIS
IS WOULD BE- TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CONSOLE AND CALL THE ROLL. S.
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE NEWMAN THE
MOST IS DUE PASS AS A BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY PLEASE- I
GLAZER HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOT
VOTING HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI
LEYVA. LEYVA HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN HI RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
FOR TWO ZERO- MEMBERS WERE TO GO
BACK AND HANDLED MATTERS THAT WE
HAD PLACED ON CALL- AS YOU MAY
KNOW AS ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY NINE BY ALLEN HAS
BEEN PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR. I WILL START WITH
THE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY BY. SENATOR BURKE
CONSULTING WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN ON THAT ABOUT THAT
MATTER. FILE ITEM TO S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY AMBERG THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CHARM THE CHAIR VOTING LIKE KERN
VOTE IS. THE REAL ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. HERTZBERG RIGHT
HERTZBERG HI. RIGHT THAT BILLS
OUT FORTY ONE WILL NEXT MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE I GLAZER AT
THE CONSOLE CALL THE ROLL FILE
ITEM FIVE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
NINE PLEASE SIR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING HI. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN HI RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE ZERO FINALLY WILL CONCLUDE
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE I GLAZER AT THE
CONSOLE WOULD CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE VICES
OF THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
BOTH VOTING EITHER CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE TWO ZERO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
THURMOND HI RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE ZERO MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY AND FOR
THOSE WHO TESTIFIED HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT ON THE PHONE
LINES YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS OF CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE COOPERATION TODAY-
THE AGENDA OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS IS COMPLETE AND. SO
WE ARE A JERK THANK YOU.